can you go into more detail about what's
going on in Belgium you can be
euthanized against your will in some
cases Belgium and Holland have both had
a euthanasia for some years Holland came
first and then Belgium I think was about
20 years ago and they have seen that
steady expansion of the criteria so that
to begin with in Belgium again it was
just for terminal ill people and now
it's expanded gradually people have
become more comfortable with it and then
people are less willing to actually go
through the criteria properly so that
doctors become less careful about
checking whether someone actually
fulfills the criteria if you go to one
doctor and they say you don't fulfill
them then you can go to another doctor
who says you do people will go around
and find a doctor that they know is
positive about euthanasia ask them and
then of course they'll help